can you help us put together a Film
Festival checklist what are some of the
do's and don'ts and important things
that a filmmaker should include in a
package - yeah well you know we can go
back to the pressing stuff I mean we we
do with our submission require an online
press kit and in PDF form or in any form
emails we don't we don't really and
we've now put in rules we don't accept
you know mailed press kits anymore but
sometime we're not gonna we won't reject
the film if we get something and they
send a press get in the mail and we're
not gonna do that but in general I think
festivals will you know they have a
rural place where they say you know we
need you know a PDF sent in or I'll
maybe online submission a lot of box of
your press kit with whatever it may be
whatever its press information articles
in your bio all that synopsis all that
stuff and your JPEG you know production
steel or whatever that stuff needs to
come in for a lot vessels you know needs
to be however they may require what they
ask so if they ask you to send it online
you send it online if they if not they
may reject the film based on just not
following those rules whether it's
something held in they don't want meal
you know for us we're not as we're
looking at the film itself and I'm not
gonna begin to concern with with that
you know someone bills in an accident
didn't send online and they sent on and
after we're not gonna disqualify you or
reject the film based on that but uh
yeah the basic check was really is just
as general it's good to have it a strong
online press kit website information
Facebook information like information
about where to find more info on the
film seem that as online presence having
your press kit sent in you know
production stills poster image or we're
not sending with your application and
your full information on contact info
the basic stuff synopsis bio all that
the more of that the better it shows
that people are taking consideration
time you know it's actually out of that
information available you know it's you
submit something and there's like no
information when we're acquiring the
rest can you send nothing at all
whatsoever you know that's a certain
lack of attention detail then you take
an accessory you know it's not it's not
something you're gonna make a decision
on I think you can too speaking for us
I'm like you know when we're looking at
the film itself this film speak for
itself
but for some festivals they will look at
their rules and be strict about the
rules if they tell you this make XYZ as
far as press kit
you know synopsis and whatnot detail
information on the film and or how the
only they asks you to submit the film if
they wanted a blank DVD as opposed to
the marking the DVD with a package on it
or you know laurels of other victories
and things like that some festivals
don't want that if you do that and their
rules are stating they don't want that
they will disqualify a rejected film so
it's important to pay attention to the
rules and but for us we for our festival
you know which end tend to be more
lenient on that you know we really do
have requirements of the basic stuff you
know what we want as far as the DVD or
on my stream you know not just a link
sent over you know we want actual the
film sent one of those two ways and then
our progress kit and then film
information and you know status by a
runtime while I stuff formats sent to us
but we're not gonna reject a film based
on oh you don't have that information
you know but you will need that
information but if you don't say it in a
timely manner we're not gonna yeah we
still want to watch this the film and
you consider the felt and go off that
and I just disqualify thought how long
should someone's Bible be I don't know I
don't know I would say not to too long
in general just because it was too long
I mean you were all busy as it is and in
any business any any industry but in
this in particular we're all you know
working we had run yeah you're running
fest you making film you know we're all
doing stuff we're all very busy you know
days can be long you know in our case
we'll watch a lot of films you know
we're going through so many different
submissions but everyone has their by
order has their information you know
we're not gonna have time to like read a
three page by you know this thing is
that good
you get some very long but we're not
gonna just don't have time to really
like just Rita we don't even need that
much information I mean it's just nice
to see a good bio on and you know and
see what they've done and it's important
that while I say that is nice to see
it's good to go you know I will look
through bios and stuff and see well what
is person done was there like background
it's interesting to note and gives you a
better a better feel for maybe what the
film might be are what you know what the
thinking is behind their film with what
they might say in their Bible so all
that stuff's good and it's important and
great but to have a very lengthy bio
it's just that at times it's tough is he
that redundant or it's just uh
it's just information that's not they
needed or you know it's not something
I'm not looking at the bios thing all
right this person's done stuff and
that's it I'm you know this is great I'm
going to Spectre film now it's not gonna
sway me that way so it's not for any
programmer probably I don't think it you
know it's nice to see it it's important
it matters but it doesn't only slightly
so I say just a bio that's you know
concise and with the main information
about someone's career it's good to get
into stuff that's really really lengthy
you know I think a lot of well let me
see myself I'm not gonna read all the
way through I don't I don't think so no
I usually don't so if it's that long no
I mean that's just just too much
what should another chronic prosecute
having it it depends cuz cuz some are
just uh you know production information
stills stories on the set articles
information on you know whatever media
they have whether it's their website
Facebook Twitter all that stuff and
that's kind of the general simple gist
of it but see the thing is some some
films have all that you know whether
they had a lot of written about them
anything has ever been written about the
film you know other from other festivals
articles from other festival they got on
a screen somewhere else good write-ups
about the film all that stuff that
should be in there but sometimes don't
have that you know obviously some films
maybe it's a premiere they don't have
much information outside of the basic
stuff whether it's just images
you know stuff in the set stories bios
and whatnot from the crew and cast and
everything and so some of that
information will be in there and that's
what we'd like to see but you know if
the film is to have any kind of history
you know outside of just being a new
film then yet we can't obviously you
can't require articles and some films
and articles written about them yet so
yeah so gonna be more full press Kate
when you have a film that's it's
daunting a more festive life but um Zuri
basics it's a lot of information you
have in your application which is you
know synopsis information on the film
bio cover letter you know a story of
finished collective the stories of the
production you know pictures from
production things like that and since
that's some of the stuff we'll we'll see
you know some
we'd like to have
you